Emma Roberts in We’re the Millers
Emma Roberts got her start as an actor at
the age of 9 in Ted Demme's 2001 drama Blow.
Since then she has had a fan base that keeps
on growing with the help of TV shows like
American Horror Story to movies like Adult
World.
With all of this experience you would think
she would be able to take direction well but
while filming a scene for We’re the Millers
she got confused.
When using a gesture that embarrassed the
actress she broke into laughter and even had
her co-star Jennifer Aniston in tears.
Amy Schumer in Trainwreck
In 2015’s Trainwreck, SNL cast member Vanessa
Bayer plays Amy Schumer’s at-work sidekick
who shares her philosophy on boys, drinking,
and dating etiquette.
Bayer never met Schumer before being cast
in the role but during auditions she wowed
the star and filmmakers with her improvisation.
During the filming of a scene the sound of
a vibrator goes off and Schumer quickly hits
Bayer with a joke.
She can’t control her exposure and the pair
shares a laugh.
Do you love Mila Kunis?
Stick around for a blooper that will make
you love her more.
Malin Åkerman in Couples Retreat
Malin Åkerman played Silk Spectre II in the
2009 superhero film Watchmen and she kicked
serious ass.
But in that same year her serious side and
fighting skills weren’t being shown in another
release, the comedy Couples Retreat.
Co-starring Vince Vaughn, Åkerman had a hard
time keeping it straight while working with
the actor.
In the outtakes she has to react off screen
to Vaughn’s calling a fellow actor Mister
Belvedere and she can’t keep it together.
She’s adorable and looks even more adorable
when laughing.
Eva Mendes in The Other Guys
When mismatched cops Will Ferrell and Mark
Wahlberg have dinner with Farrell’s beautiful
wife Eve Mendes they discuss their personal
life.
Wahlberg can’t take his eyes off Mendes
and we can’t stop laughing.
Ferrell improvises jokes while Wahlberg and
Mendes try to keep a straight face but once
he relates his wife’s injuries to that of
a German Shepard all three of them can’t
control themselves.
Now if only Wahlberg and us can stop starring
at Mendes.
Megan Fox in This Is 40
Breaking herself out of action films and into
comedies, Megan Fox surprised audience members
with her comedy chops in 2012’s This is
40.
Surrounded by comedy legends like Albert Brooks
and John Lithgow, Fox held her own in her
scenes and added a dimension we all can like.
One particular scene that everyone remembers
is when Leslie Mann fondles Fox’s breast.
Fox might remember it for another reason,
because she couldn’t stop laughing at the
jokes Mann was making while filming.
Ryan Reynolds in Deadpool
Ryan Reynolds performance as the Merc with
a Mouth is filled with violence, crude humor
and audiences loved every minute of it.
So it wouldn’t be surprising to learn that
the outtakes are filled with these same content.
When Reynolds persuaded his X-Men comrades,
Colossus and Negasonic Teenage Warhead to
help him save Vanessa, he improvised numerous
jokes to speed them up.
This broke his co-star into laughs and we
did the same when we saw the movie.
Natalie Portman in Your Highness
Saying the word beaver in a movie isn’t
hard but relate that to the female anatomy
and it might be cause for laughter.
In 2011’s Your Highness, Natalie Portman
had just that problem.
When delivering the line, “It's been burning
in my beaver since the day I lost my brothers.”
the actress kept breaking up.
She even tried to change her line to get through
it but that didn’t work either.
We can watch Portman butcher a line all day
long but luckily she finally delivered it.
Mila Kunis in Bad Moms
When three overworked and under-appreciated
moms are pushed beyond their limits, they
ditch their conventional responsibilities
for a jolt of long overdue freedom and comedy.
Mila Kunis stars alongside Kristen Bell and
Kathryn Hahn in the 2016 comedy Bad Moms.
When Kunis confronts NFL player turned actor
J.J.
Watts his responses break her into laughter.
Throughout her scenes with him, he has her
in stitches due to the sad turn of events
in his life.
They seemed to really enjoy each other on
set.
Steve Carell in The 40-Year-Old Virgin
Steve Carell grew to stardom in the 2005 comedy
hit, The 40-Year-Old Virgin and his star has
only grown brighter since.
The subject of the film was bike riding Andy
Stitzer who at the age of forty decided to
find a sexual companion.
His love interest Trish finds a model of the
female reproductive system and confronts him.
Carell fumbles his way through an explanation
in the film but the outtakes show more.
In the bloopers Carell tries different ways
to explain the anatomy part without sounding
too pervy but of course, he’s hilarious.
Chloë Grace Moretz in Neighbors 2: Sorority
Rising
The Georgian born, Chloë Grace Moretz has
been no stranger to R-rated content even as
a child, since she has stared in a line of
horror reboots and the superhero black comedy
series, Kick-Ass.
When acting in the film Neighbors 2: Sorority
Rising we got to see more of a grownup side
of her alongside Zac Efron and Seth Rogen;
and during outtakes we got to even see a naughty.
She dances and gets frisky with a co-star.
We bet he wasn’t complaining about this
outtake.
There you have it, 10 bloopers that you won’t
forget and probably never want to.
Did we miss any of your favorite bloopers?
Sound off in the comments below and remember
to subscribe to Screen Rant for more awesome
videos.
Remember to check out another one of our videos
to enjoy another fun list.
Thanks for watching.